good evening when i was elected
leader of the labour party i said i
would
always act in the national interest
that's why as the nation continues to
fight against this dreadful virus
my priority will always be the same as
yours
to save lives and protect our nhs
sadly despite all the sacrifices
and heroism of the british people it's
clear
that we are not through this yet the
picture presented
by the government's medical advisors
this week
was stark and it was clear
infections are rising hospital
admissions
are increasing and we know
from bitter experience where that can
lead
that's why the government had to
introduce further restrictions last
night
we support this and i urge everyone
to follow the new guidance and the rule
of law
while these restrictions are now
necessary they were not
inevitable the return of this virus
and the return of restrictions are not
an act of god
they're a failure of government the
british people have done
everything asked of them but i'm afraid
the government has not we're a great
country we shouldn't have one of the
highest death rates
in the world or one of the worst
recessions
it's a national scandal that we still
don't have
a testing system that works or a plan
to protect our care homes it shouldn't
be like this
people shouldn't have to travel hundreds
of miles to get a test
for their child for themselves
or for their relatives and we should be
able to give our older people
the dignity security and respect
they deserve the government needs to fix
testing
fast because that's the only way
we can get control of the virus and
prevent
further restrictions and we also need to
see a plan b for the economy
because it makes no sense to bring in
new restrictions
at the same time as phasing out support
for jobs and businesses there was
nothing
in the prime minister's statement last
night to protect people's jobs
businesses or our town centres and high
streets
no clarity about what happens when the
furlough scheme ends
that's a huge gap and a huge mistake
and it could lead to a wave of job
losses this winter
we need a national effort to protect
jobs
and prevent a second lockdown so i've
offered to work with the prime minister
to do whatever we can to save lives
and protect livelihoods that offer
remains open my door is
always open the weeks and months ahead
will be difficult and i know that
there's real frustration
and anger about the mistakes that the
government has made
in the last few months but we will get
through this
the darkness will lift a better future
is possible for our country
a country built on the values that have
held us together
during this pandemic decency
fairness opportunity
compassion and security
a future where britain is everything it
can be
the best place to grow up in and the
best place
to grow old in that's the future
i want for my children and for my
country
that's why i do this together
we can build it